this is Joe Harris and we're playing
that's my guy this is cousin of Garrett
temple Anthony Tolliver is Malcolm
really I actually wouldn't guess that
he's never mentioned that no no this guy
for like 10 years never mentioned it
this was awesome because this was the
first time that Virginia had won the ACC
tournament championship since 1976 so
it's sort of like obviously their
national champs this past year with this
new site kind of beginning 2014 of all
that one of my teammates Matthew
Dellavedova there we go the wedding
party this was actually at his house in
Milwaukee it was a lot of fun so deli is
Australian obviously and most of his
groomsmen from Australia I'd like to
have a good time so it was a pretty
eventful wedding weekend they are the
great I need some more hands
I need a probably a couple more more
context
and I'm connected with him I'm gonna see
this Chris long yeah I was trying to
think all the football players I yeah
yeah this is the UVA crew right here
chris is a little bit older that Malcolm
Justin and I but obviously the three of
us played together over here in
Charlottesville a plane together at
Virginia I mean obviously you're gonna
get close to one another just teammate
spending a lot of time but a lot of the
guys like Coach Bennett recruits to the
UVA are all kind of very similar
personality wise and so you kind of just
you know easily shamelessly get along
almost from the get-go and so the guys
that I played with ever Jamie at all
some of my closest friends even to this
day playing Church league today you is
the current team a flyin high this
figure do what I do
yeah yeah yeah he's the best I don't
know Jill could handle them now he might
block your shot Tony Bennett said this
he said this about you give me one more
clear okay they were the secretary of
their student government in high school
give me one more okay her husband's in
the cannabis and hemp industry wave say
it again
her husband is in the cannabis and hemp
industry and then say the quote I don't
know if Joe could handle them now
they might block his shot she's probably
talking about my sister
JC yeah haha yeah that was my rookie
year my sister obviously and then my
brother-in-law they went to Washington
State together she played volleyball
there and he played football there I
have three sisters and we're all within
I guess from the oldest to the youngest
six years of each other so pretty
tight-knit family growing up this is Joe
Harris and that was that's my guy